So I feel like the big issue with today's generation is bullying.
Why does bullying continue and why doesn't anybody put a stop to it?
So I thought let's put a crime...
...and let it happen right in front of people's faces and see what they would do.
Because of course, change starts with the people, right?
Yes, it does.
Let's go.
So you're really not gonna help me with my paper?
No.
You're really not gonna help me with my paper?
Let me go. No. I'm sorry.
You remember what happened last time?
Please.
Stop, stop, no.
Why?
Are you gonna help me?
No, no.
Hey, everybody looking right now.
There's a camera right there and you guys just walked away from a guy getting brutally beat...
...and you guys did nothing to help him.
To stop bullying in America would be really sincere...
...and kind of you guys to try to do something and stop something like that at hand,...
...instead of just walking away and acting like blind victims to something that's going on.
He was about to get really hurt.
I was about to beat him up.
I'm sorry but I don't think this might be a nuisance.
I don't really want to get in any trouble...
...so I'm so sorry about that.
What?
What's going on here?
What is it to you?
What is it for me?
Yeah.
Someone's beating up somebody else, in my university, that's something to do with me.
Is it your problem?
Yes it is.
Can I tell you something?
We just wanted to see what would happen in this kind of predicament.
The camera's right there.
Please don't kill me because you're scaring me right now.